and a March has been organized by the
land workers Alliance and this is a
collection of farmers and Farmers
families and Associates who are very
keen to farm in a new sustainable way
farming has gone down a wormhole driven
has been driven down a wormhole let's be
honest about it uh since the second war
world war with an enormous dependence on
uh industrial levels of farming and
chemicals fertilizers so on and so forth
but here we're looking at a collection
of farmers intelligent people who
recognize they need a new future for
farming because we need to reshape the
way that we impact our landscape and
what they've already proved is that a
methodology works and these people are
producing top quality food with good
standards of Animal Welfare
um for people in the UK whilst at the
same time ensuring that they look after
the environment both for wildlife and to
ensure that they have a rural economy
which can last into the future so it's
not surprising that conservationists
like myself are very keen to work with
these people and support them at a time
when their future is very much
understood
so why is their future under threat well
the government post-brexit promised us
public good for public money in the form
of these albums environmental Land
Management schemes
um they were subsidies to pay Farmers
for farming in a way which would support
the environment and ensure that it had
resilience into the future and these are
the farmers are the Pioneers who've
basically been doing this and and making
it work this should be their time this
should be a time when we pay them
properly for looking after the
environment and producing top quality
food well the government appeared to be
on the brink of renaging on the
implementation of this type of subsidy
and perhaps even going backwards to
paying family a farmers simply for just
having an acreage of land something that
we hoped we got past and and we are Keen
along with the farming fertility to make
sure that this doesn't happen there are
a lot of threats that are hovering if
you like after the last three weeks of
government the potential to return into
fracking further exploration of fossil
fuels and then their exploitation they
are poised to an age on the deal to stop
live animal export to you know to
prevent the import of foie gras and
trophy so we environmentalists and
conservationists are understandably
concerned and it's it's at this point
when we really need to unite with people
who have a care about the environment
and its future and let me assure you
that this Collective of farmers and
their supporters are very much those
people
well yes and the government would say
would it not that some of the steps it's
taking are because of they're in the
National interest because of worries
about energy security they also
um might there are some people that will
say that there are issues with food
security as well and there are some
farmers who say that the priority has to
be food production over the protection
of nature at a time when food prices are
rising across the country well I would
disagree obviously forth lightly with
that and I imagine most of the people
that we're marching from Parliament
Square
um from 12 o'clock today would join me
in that opinion um the future of food
security is dependent on a healthy
functional uh Eco you know ecosystems in
our Countryside and that's from the soil
up that means looking after the land
which provides us with that food and if
we continue to abuse that land with an
over-dependence on chemicals and
Industrial levels of farming then we
will destroy basically the fundamental
fabric of that that we require to feed
as a species there is no doubt at all
that we have researched understood and
developed methods to to look after our
landscape so that we can provide food
security good quality affordable food
for people in the UK whilst at the same
time looking after wildlife and the
environment and these Farmers as I say
are the people that have already proved
that they are up against lobbyists who
want to continue to pump our Countryside
full of noxious chemicals and high
levels of long-term damaging fertilizer
because that's business as usual but the
world is indicating to us at this point
in time that we're in the midst of a
climate and biodiversity of new
emergency and we cannot continue with
business as usual it's been bad business
it's got us into a mess so we need to
make sure that we wake up and and raise
awareness of these concerns and that's
what this March is all about
environmental terms continue to put up
with short-termism short-termism isn't
going to fix it it might it might keep a
few jobs and put some money in the purse
tomorrow but for your and my children
grandchildren so on and so forth we need
far broader more intelligent thinking
and that's what people are about and
they deserve support okay we must leave
it there Chris Packham good to talk to
you this morning thanks very much indeed
for your time you're welcome